California lawmakers passing a massive
214 point eight billion dollar budget
this week it includes 98 million dollars
to let some illegal immigrants under 26
enroll in the state-funded health
insurance at six hundred and fifty
million bucks for local governments to
tackle the homelessness crisis
Democratic governor Gavin Newsom is
expected to sign this but is this just
another case of Democrats throwing money
at the problem joining us to react from
la michael knowles our old friend host
of the michael knowles show good morning
sir
ed good to see you so what's your
immediate reaction to just throwing
money at these problems well not only is
it just throwing money at the problems
it's actually making the problems worse
so in the case of illegal immigration
they now have california subsidizing the
health insurance of illegal aliens where
the families make upwards of 150
thousand five hundred dollars per year
the the meanwhile they're paying for
that by the way by instituting a mandate
on legal residents to subsidize that in
that issue the issue here isn't illegal
immigrants paying for health care the
issue is illegal immigration itself
right and so if you create that
incentive what do you think you're gonna
get you already have sanctuary states
sanctuary cities all over the state what
are you gonna get more illegal
immigration it's exactly the same issue
on homelessness I live in LA we have
60,000 homeless people here in the last
12 months that has increased by 12%
meanwhile the economy has gone
gangbusters this isn't a problem of
money this isn't a problem of employment
we have record low unemployment it's a
problem of addiction and mental health
what is California gonna do they can
throw money at it that won't solve the
problem what they need to do is enforce
the law they need to get people who need
psychiatric care care and they need to
get people who should be off the streets
off the streets but what do they do yeah
decriminalize defecation on the streets
and they decriminalized tent cities
that's not going to fix them it's
disgusting what we're seeing on those
streets and Tucker and others here this
network I've been pointing that out I
want to give the governor a fair shot
here's what Gavin Newsom said back in
January about why he's taking some of
these initiatives watch every person
should have access to quality of four
health care far away judges and
politicians may turn back our progress
but we will never waver in our pursuit
of guaranteed health care for all
Californians so real quick of course if
you're here your tax payer you should
get some kind of health care and we need
to figure that out on a global scale
here in the country it's being fought
out in Congress and with the president
but illegal immigrants how in the world
can you justify paying that of course we
all want every wonderful thing for every
single person and the way that we affect
that in our politics is through good
government if you want to talk about the
real problematic incentives here it's on
the issue of voters because California
voters are the ones who keep sending
these people back to the state
government right who are not fixing the
problems they're throwing away our money
on making the problems Michael you are
been great about calling that out on the
state level but I'm hearing on social
media that you may be going to a much
bigger stage Sarah Sanders is stepping
down there's a White House press
secretary job open I saw this boomlet
on social media but then I saw maybe
you're pushing it because your Twitter
handle is potential White House press
secretary Michael Knowles are you
pushing this or others oh that's an old
nickname that my friends gave me in high
school a total coincidence if I were
called on to serve of course I would I
will say having gone all around the
country to these college campuses with
shrieking hordes of leftists there I
think this would prepare me very well to
deal with Jim Acosta every day so see
so apparently you're the campaign
manager of the campaign and we shall see
Michael Mills
we always appreciate avignon good to see
it